todos pendientes del frente ucraniano
pero también de lo que decidamos con una
semana que puede ser clave para la
guerra parece que el viernes se
producirá un importante discurso de
Vladimir Putin que podría ser para
rubricar la anexión de los territorios
que ahora están apurando sus últimas
horas de votación en Ucrania Tony sluis
y también las nuevas conquistas de Moscú
las zonas que parcialmente tiene Rusia
ocupadas en jerson y también en
saborilla en cuanto acaben de contarse
los votos el parlamento ruso pasará a
aprobar esa anexión y después la última
palabra la tendrá Vladimir Putin que
podría además aprovechar ese discurso
para lanzar alguna advertencia a
occidente como ha hecho en los últimos
días tal vez de tipo nuclear incluso
para decretar aquí en Rusia el estado
guerra o la ley Marcial